[Music]
thanks for watching the live coco cam
it's been a pleasure almost being here
go to uh coco no
check out no check out team coco
okay i can do this
jesus christ i mean can we just film
while i'm doing it look come here look
at this i've got him holding that that's
my auto cue i'm in a dressing room next
to a toilet they're doing a show there's
people walking around upstairs
i'm not getting paid
sake
how much more do i have to help conan
it's like a [ __ ] charity case
a little sick kid make a wish foundation
i'm taking him to disneyland next year
oh look him little skinny ginger irish
boy let him go on the rides
he grew a beard
he's clever that one of those people are
getting the guinness book of records for
doing full just sitting there look i
grew a beard well done i've got the
longest anal hair in the world
[ __ ] useless
right let's do this
i failed i failed they've made me feel
bad for not being able to read this
piece of paper
i've got dinner i've done the show i
didn't get paid for that either right
right let's do it
check out team coco for all things conan
and ricky gervais.com for all things
[Music]